I'm not cheering out of any sort of
- particularly chair this session but
Chesapeake
don't ask me - I take the intention of
this session which i think is officially
called philosophy / science should be to
discuss what role philosophy can play
for scientists and pushing that forward
and what role science can play for
philosophers in terms of pushing their
agenda forward I'd like to encourage a
real open exchange if we can have it in
the sense of less oppressing of
preexisting theses you know which has
been interesting over the past couple of
days but really just an opportunity to
see if we can really ask each other
genuine sort of questions about what we
could do really in the spirit of moving
forward you know really is there
something that we can all walk away and
ponder when go back to our various labs
desks in my case couch and I'm gonna let
Massimo introduce really in terms of
content something to give us to talk
about but I think we should feel free to
riff as we like on this issue of what we
can offer each other in terms of kind of
split to different communities you know
science and philosophy what can we
really offer each other and will this
dialogue continue when we leave okay
Massimo right so I have a special
interest I suspect we all have an
interest obviously otherwise we wouldn't
be here in the rushes between science
and philosophy I think of my own as
perhaps a little more special than usual
simply because I have this unusual
background having been a practice in
scientist and a prac and now a
practicing philosopher and having
actually had gone to school for both
cases and so I can I feel that I have a
maybe not unique but certainly unusual
perspective in I mean actually being a
petitioner in both in both disciplines
and see exactly where each side comes
from where when when they dismiss or
criticize or make fun of the other so
I'm gonna put up a few slides as a way
to introduce the discussion
of course I think that everything that
you're gonna see in the next few minutes
is gonna be very uncontroversial so we
can pack five minutes after this and go
home but I'd be surprised if that's
actually going to be the outcome so so
you know we're supposed to talk about
science philosophy n by the way that
little thing in the middle
scientism whatever that is so we need to
sort of agree on that one that is so
first of all I'd say that I suggest that
we don't play semantic games and that
when we talk about science and
philosophy we'll talk about the academic
disciplines as they're practiced so you
know science cannot be taken to be just
whatever deals with facts just like
philosophy cannot be whatever deals with
thinking because otherwise well
scientists and philosophers and we
haven't said anything particularly
interesting I think so just to make more
clear what I mean by that the thing on
the hopper left it's a scientific fact
or a collection of scientific facts the
fact that I live nearby the Queensboro
Bridge is not a scientific fact it's
just a fact okay so I take it scientific
facts would be a subset of facts about
the world arrived at by the methods of
science and by the community of science
not just simple observations about how
the world works similarly with
philosophy you know the one up on the
upper left is actual philosophy the one
on the lower right it's not and you know
that's ron Hubbard over there
[Music]
so again you know if we want to make a
distinction it's not like oh I got a
philosophy and and therefore I'm a
philosopher now it doesn't it doesn't
work that way
just this morning I got as a as a part
of our Twitter feed that has been going
on for the last few days you know
somebody made the the usual predictable
comment that all the philosophy is gone
and so technical and academic that it's
essentially irrelevant to the rest of us
and my response to that is yes true but
that's true for any academic discipline
most of what scientists do is irrelevant
to the rest of us that's the nature of
academia now you can say that that's a
good thing a bad thing or whatever I
think it's inevitable but it's not it's
I don't see why people sort of single
out this one field as opposed to and
then let everybody else pass from that
account so science in my view becomes a
particular type of structural social
activity characterized by empirically
driven hypothesis testing about the way
the world works peer review technical
journals and so on and so forth that's
what I mean by science I don't mean just
getting up on going out of the you know
in downstairs and say oh there is a road
across the street that's a fact but it's
not science similarly I mean the
philosophy is broadly speaking about
deploying logic and general tools of
reasoning an argument to reflect on
broad ranges of subject matters like
epistemology ethics aesthetics and so on
and so forth as well as to reflect on
other disciplines and these are the
philosophies of a lot of philosophy
today is in fact a philosophy of
citizens as philosophy of physics
philosophy of biology this philosophy
chemistry that is philosophy language
there is philosophy blah blah blah and
it's sort of you can think of that as
sort of a meta reflection on those
disciplines and of course practitioners
of those metal reflections better be
informed and respectful of those
disciplines which is not always the case
but those that are actually making
interesting I think contributions but
contributions to what you might say now
come up in a second
so another important point I think is is
to get readies the philosophy is not in
the business of advancing science and we
got science for that and therefore you
know it doesn't make any sense to me I
hear this occupation over and over you
know what has laws be done for us
recently well why do you think the
philosophy is supposed to be doing
something for you it's not it's a
different discipline it has different
concerns different methods different
different all sorts of things now some
philosophy is in fact continuous with
science and those are the philosophies
of science philosophy mathematics
philosophy physics
there are certain number of papers a
rarely it's small one however in in the
full in the in the full data philosophy
there is number of papers where if you
read them you really want to be able to
tell whether they've been written by a
scientist or a philosopher a
mathematician or philosopher in fact
often they bring by both there is a
number of philosophers who publish in
mathematics or physics or biology
journals and vice versa a number of
physicists and mathematicians and
biologists who publish in philosophy
journals and those are really at
interface those are about conceptual
clarification of borderline areas
between science and philosophy but that
I think it's a fairly small area it's
not the main concern of philosophy it's
not even the main concern the philosophy
of then the question of how philosophy
makes progress comes up we think we all
have an understanding of how science
makes progress of course there will be
that there are volumes written about
that sort of stuff by philosophers among
other things my social scientists etc
but I think we can in this group we can
assume that we know how science makes
progress philosophy I think makes
progress by a very different route it's
really I think of it as an exploration
of logical space so you start with a
certain problem if somebody comes up
with certain number of ideas then people
sort of criticize those ideas then there
is a response to those criticism and
things move and become more complex and
move away occasionally positions are
entirely abandoned like logical
positivism for instance in other case
the debate is not resolved but it has
improved for instance the debate between
scientific realism and scientific
anti-realism in philosophy science it
hasn't been settled but there have been
novel positions and there certainly
original positions that are not tenable
anymore because of criticism so if I
think that is a way in which one can
make sense of the idea that philosophy
doesn't make progress
[Applause]
let me bring bring up the bad boy of
physics who famously said the philosophy
science is about is useful to scientists
and ornithology is to birds I think I
agree now there are different ways of
cashing out that concept the nesting
falah a reply would be well that's
because birds are too stupid to
understand ornithology but i won't go
there it's true and that's because
ornithologist are concerned with
different things from what birds are
concerned with so clearly there is no
this very little overlap there's one
area of overlap interestingly however
ornithology one of the consequences of
Ornithology of course is that it
provides information about rare birds
and you know things that are about to go
extent and so those birds probably
should be concerned with our mythology
I'm not suggesting these are direct and
healthy they obviously between
philosophy and science but I do think
that that is the that is the capture
this idea that broadly speaking the two
disciplines are in fact separate and
then there are some areas of contact
what about scientism well there's much
of definitions out there of scientism I
picked on to that I think I sort of
capture most of the of what's going on
in that debate in the strong sense I
think scientism is the view that only
scientific claims or only questions that
can be addressed by science are
meaningful okay so you can think of it
as of the positivist version of in a
weaker sense or somewhat weakens weaker
sense it is the view that methods of the
Natural Sciences can and should be
applied to any subject matter okay I
think the first one is undefensible I
think the second one needs to be
qualified but I'm sure that we'll have
some discussion about ok
it I think the second one it should be
qualified but we can I can get on board
and on some version of the second one I
think the first one is it's in fact too
strong for example there's I think there
is a pretty good number of things where
science has little or nothing to say
about I count math and logic in there I
understand that a lot of people think of
math as as is a science I think that's
not a tenable position because it's a
very different kind of activity it
doesn't depend at all analytical
information about the rest of the world
it's very relevant to science so it's
logic but their definitions certain
aesthetic ethics and so on it's fourth
now aesthetics that should be a nice
there now even in aesthetics and ethics
I don't think the facts are irrelevant
nor do I think that scientific
information of some stuff that deals
with those things is irrelevant which is
why I would accept the second version
the weaker version of scientists but
largely one can do aesthetics in ethics
and logic and math without any input
from science and just be fine with
anyway yeah of course we discover
something we don't invent it I'm on
board with that okay there's something
about the difference between discovery
and sort of analysis and I do see that
as a putting math and logic somewhere in
between that they're not really a
subject matter that's totally separate
from science I mean you can say suppose
as a physicist I have a physical
scenario in mind which forces me or
other physicists you know larger string
theorists these days to make
mathematical discoveries so so it makes
it a foggier not just motivationally but
they're saying there is a physical
reality even if it's one I haven't yet
probed experimentally but I'm you know
for thought assuming that this is going
to constrain the kind of math I think
that's to discuss yeah I'd like to
finish it too calling one one more two
more slides and yeah I think that's an
interesting discussion that's chair of
the session
allowing people to interrupt yeah that's
fine powers going to your head
it's a good thing she doesn't have a
Taser but you're right that the I
certainly wouldn't go to the point of
sayin this with where Jerry we've had
this discussion in the past and I think
we clarified ourselves no there is no
territory that cannot be invaded by or
or talked by the other side before
talking about intellectual issues I
think any competent intelligent person
ought to be able to talk about it but
that comes with a responsibility so just
like we expect rightly philosophers to
get the science correct when they're
talking about science and we chastise
them if they don't again correctly I
think the same should be going for
scientists yeah yeah well yes okay so
anyway that would those were just
examples my general idea in all of this
is is I guess I'm a little bit of old
fashioned from that perspective because
I think actually did this whole thing
ought to be too looked at as from the
point of view of what used to be called
San Thea which is a Latin word for
knowledge in the broader sense see
Anthea there was actually a journal
called Cynthia when I was an undergrad
word
and then it unfortunately closed down
that's right there's no more knowledge
in the broad sense which exactly there's
only Technic and in knowledge in the
broad sense there includes science for
sure philosophy mathematics and logic
that was sort of the broader realm of
and these things are not seen as
completely separate fields are seen lies
largely looking at different things in
different ways but they're sort of
supposed to interact with each other
into giving us give us sort of knowledge
in the broad sense
want to say goodbye everyone enjoyed
visiting with y'all it was fun thank you
um now I also think that that knowledge
is more narrow concept than
understanding and human beings seek
understanding not just knowledge and I'm
trying to run into a distinction here
that will bring therefore in things like
music literature and the broader
humanities because those I think as
Rebecca was saying just yesterday are
necessary for an understanding because
we're human beings we think in a certain
way we don't we don't just think in
terms of equations we don't just think
in terms of logic well we understand
things in a broad you know using a broad
swath of approaches which include those
things I'm not saying that therefore we
should be doing you know novel novelized
version of quantum physics but I'm
saying that it's we're talking about
scientism as this is the only way to
know and to understand things that's not
gonna hold and finally let me remind you
this quote by Isaac Asimov
anti-intellectualism it's been a
constant winding thread winding its way
through our political and cultural life
nurtured by the false notion that
democracy means that my ignorance is
just as good as your knowledge I mean
this is our common enemy
in the United States there's a very good
tradition sociology of actually tracking
in different types of
anti-intellectualism the United States I
think we're all concerned with these
kind of things and I think we don't do
any any good surface to the cause of
fighting anti intellectual is when we
start finding about your stuff is
nonsense that one is idiotic and so on
and so forth
in fact I will go as far as saying that
any broad claim like that is itself anti
intellectual and feeds into these sort
of things that that is problematic in
American society so that's it that's
that's what I want to say
you